[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله شهد قطاع غزه
انفجار عبوه محليه الصنع بالقرب من منازل
وسيارات عدد من قيادي حركه ال فتح في
القطاع الانفجارات التي لم تخلف صابات
تذكر دعت حماس لتقديم مقترفيها للعداله
بينما اتهم تصريحات لبعض قيادات فتح
الحركه التي تسيطر على غزه بالتسبب فيها
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ناقشه في محورين ما هي
الرسائل والاهداف التي تضمنتها التفجيرات
التي استهدفت منازل القيادات الفتحاويه في
غزه وكيف يبدو مستقبل المصالحه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه على ضوء الاثار التي نجمت عن
تفجيرات
[موسيقى]
القطاع لم تكشف التحقيقات بعد عن الجهه
التي تقف وراء تفجيرات غزه لكن الاكيد هو
انها القت بذلها القويه على مسار المصالحه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اثر بدا جاليا في
تصعيد كلامي من قبل قيادات من فتح اتجاه
حماس وفي تاجيل رئيس وزراء حكومه التوافق
الوطني رامي الحمد الله زياره مركان مقرره
لغزه لاجل غير مسمى تعقيدات تطرح اكثر من
سؤال حول صاحب المصلحه في تفخيخ مسار
المصالحه ومنعه من اي يبلغ
اهدافه عشره تفجيرات ضد منازل وممتلكات
قيادي الصف الاول لحركه فتح في غزه عشيه
زياره رئيس حكومه التوافق الوطني
الفلسطينيه وعدد من الوزراء للقطاع زياره
الغيت بعد ما وصفته حركه ف بالعمل
الارهابي محمله في الوقت ذاته حركه حماس
المسؤوليه عن هذا الحادث الخطير قد تكون
الجهه المسؤوله عنه مجهوله ولكن الرساله
واضحه نسف جهود المصالحه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه القياده الفلسطينيه ستارس بكل
جديه حقيقه ما جرى
وسنعيد النظر
حقيقه في كل علاقتنا مع حركه حماس اذا ثبت
ايضا بالدليل القاطع ان حركه حماس وراء
هذا الموضوع من جهتها دانت حماس التفجيرات
واتهمت الحكومه بالعجز عن اداء دورها كان
عليه بدل من ان يلغي الزياره ان ياتي الى
غزه للقيام بمسؤولياته رامي الحمد الله
يتهرب من القيام بمسؤولياته وهذه النتيجه
هناك فراغ اداري كبير نتيجه عجز الحكومه
وفشلها في اداره الوضع في غزه قد تكون
نبره التصريحات والتصريحات المضاده خفت
بين المسؤولين في القطاع والضفه بيد ان
ذلك لا يلغي وجود احتقان بين الاخوه
الفرقاء جلي ان اكثر من طرف ليس من مصلحته
نجاح المصالحه الفلسطينيه وتحقيق الوحده
بين جميع مكونات الشعب بغض النظر عن الجهه
التي تقف وراء تفجيرات غزه يرى الحمساوي
انها رمت لزياده عزله حركتهم وخلق ازمه
جديده بينها وبين فتح ليس من مصلحه
اسرائيل وغيرها نجاح حكومه التوافق الوطني
التي ولدت بعد سبع سنوات من القطيعه
والخصام بين
الفلسطينيين توقيت التفجيرات لم يكن صدفه
ف غزه كانت تستعد لاحياء ذكرى وفاه الرئيس
الراحل ياسر عرفات في الحادي عشر من
نوفمبر استهدفت احدى التفجيرات المنصه
التي كانت ستجرى عليها وقائع ذكرى رحيل
الزعيم
الفلسطيني دويها قد يكون استهدف في نظر
قراءات صرف الانظار عن استفزازات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وانتهاكاته الخطيره للحرم
الش وحدها الحكمه ستنق حكومه التوافق
الفلسطينيه ومسار المصالحه الوطنيه التي
ليس من مصلحه اي فلسطيني فتحوي كان ام حم
سويا في
اجهاضه ومناقشه موضوع حلقتنا ينضم الينا
من غزه مشير المصري القيادي في حركه حماس
ومن رام الله ينضم الينا كل من مفق مطر
عضو المجلس الثوري لحركه فتح والدكتور
احمد عزم استاذ الدراسات الدوليه في جامعه
بيرزيت مرحبا بكم ضيوفنا الكرام استاذ
موفق مطر لماذا سارعت فتح الى اتهام حماس
بالوقوف وراء هذه التفجيرات
دون ان تنتظر نتائج التحقيق على ماذا
استندت في هذا
الاتهام كما قال ع اللجنه المركيه كما قال
عضو اللجنه المركزيه الاخ عزام الاحمد وهو
مفوض العلاقات الوطنيه وايضا المسؤول عن
ملف انهاء الانقسام المصالحه مع حماس ان
معلومات لدى
الحركه اوليه تفيد بان منفذي العمليه
والمشرفين عليهم من داخل حماس هذا اولا
ثانيا حمله التحريض التي سبقت هذه العمليه
والتي ممكن اذا اريناك صوره واحده منها
على الاقل بامكانكم ان تعرفوا من المحرض
فعلا على هذه العمليه التي استهدفت حركه
التحرر الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وال هويه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اولا في الوعي الوطني
الفلسطيني عندما يصور بهاء ياسين وهو
المقرب اعلاميا من قيادات
حماس الشهيد ياسر عرفات رمز الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ورمز الثوره الفلسطينيه
المعاصره ورمز حركه التحرر
الوطنيه العربيه والعالميه ايضا وال
النائب الاول والدائم لمؤتمر ومنظمه
التعاون
الاسلاميه قبل استشهاده حتى قبل استشهاده
عندما ما يصور رئيس الشعب الفلسطيني
الشهيد ياسر عرفات بهذا الشكل الذي ترونه
امامكم نعتقد انه فتح لم تبادر الى
التصعيد كما جاء في تقريركم ولكن هذا
التصعيد سبق هذه العمليه هي انا نعم
سميناها بعمليه ارهابيه هي في الحقيقه
متزامنه مع جرائم الحرب ضد الانسانيه
وجرائم الحرب لدوله الاحتلال وجيش
الاحتلال ومستوطنيه في القدس في الحقيقه
ان حماس قد قدمت خدمه مجانيه لدوله
الاحتلال في هذا المجال للتغطيه على هذه
الجريمه التي
تحدث قبل حت العدوان الاخير على شعبنا وت
هذ الادله هي الادله المفترض انها تكون
واضحه لكن اريد ان اعرف اذا كانت لديكم
ادله على ان هناك عمليات كانت ستقع ضد
اهداف لفتح في غزه لماذا لم تبلغوا قياده
حماس بذلك حتى توقف اي اي توجه لجهه
منداخل حماس اذا افترضنا ذلك ضد اهداف
فتحاويه في غزه
او اولا نق نحن لم نقل انه كانت لدينا
ادله حول العمليات مسبقه ولكن المعلومات
التي تم جمعها
حتى مؤتمر الصحفي للجنه المركزيه لحركه
فتح كانت تقول هذه المعلومات ان هنالك
الذين قاموا بهذه العمليه تعرفهم حماس وهم
قاموا بهذا الامر تحت جناحها جناح 15
تفجيرا في مناطق متعدده في في قطاع غزه
وتحديدا في مدينه غزه اكثرها هل يعقل ان
بكل هذه السيطره الامنيه لميليشيا حماس و
مسلحيها لا يمكنها ان تضبط هذا
الامر سي مشير مصري مشير مصري يعني انتم
تسيطرون على قطاع غزه يقول استاذ موفق مطر
وتسيطر على الجانب الامني ف كيف يق ان
تحدث 15 تفجيرا يث تحدث هذه التفجيرات
متزامنه ولم تتمكنوا انتم من يعني تصدي
لخ بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا تحيه لك
والتحيه لضيوفك ولجميع المشاهدين اولا
حركه حماس ومنذ اللحظه الاولى ادانت هذه
الاحداث الاجراميه واكدت على ضروره التروي
واجراء التحقيقات اللازمه وتقديم
المتورطين الى العداله الفلسطينيه من اي
جهه كانوا هؤلاء الامر الثاني اعتقد ان
توقيت هذه الاحداث الاجراميه جاء في مرحله
خطيره جدا بخاصه في ضلال توجهنا نحو
المصالحه الفلسطينيه وتثبيت اركانها
ودعوتنا مرارا وتكرارا لحكومه الوفاق
الوطني القدوم لقطاع غزه واستبشر خيرا
بقدومها للمره الثانيه التي كان مفترض ان
ياتي غدا لتثبيت اركان المصالحه
الفلسطينيه والمضي في بقيه ملف فاتها
والامر الثاني كذلك هو لاشغال الساحه
الفلسطينيه عن الهم الاكبر وهو ما يتعرض
له ما تتعرض له مدينه القدس والاقصى من
مؤامره كبرى وبذور وجود انتفاضه ثالثه في
وجه هذا العدو الصهيوني الامر الثالث وهو
لا شك ان هذه الاحداث الاجراميه جاءت
لتخريب اجواء المهرجان مهرجان الراحل
الرئيس ياسر عرفات الذي تمت كل الموافقات
مع الاجهزه الامنيه في قطاع غزه
والذي بالتاكيد تمت كل الترتيبات بهذا ال
الشان ونحن في حركه حماس قلنا واكد من ذ
قبل اننا معنيون بانجاح هذا المهرجان
ومعنيون بشخص السي الراحل ياس عرفات
باعتباره رمز فلسطيني ووطني جامع لل الكل
وليس مقتصر فقط لحركه فتح فهو رئيس
فلسطيني صادق ومعنيون بانجاح هذا المهرجان
والاهم والاهم في ذلك صوره اسمح لي عرض
صوره ل لاحد رمو احد المقربين من حماس و
وهو يصور الرئيس الفلسطيني الان هو
يعرضوها الرئيس الراحل ياسي العرفات ك
كفار على على راسه كوفي يعني انا لا لا
ارى جيدا ما ما هو مكتوب ولكن هو امر
المسي كيف سمحت حماس
بذلك يعني انا لا ادري من اين اتى بهذه
الصوره ومن هو الشخص الذي قال عنه انه
مقرب من حركه حماس على صعيد الشخصي لا
اعرف هذا مقع بهاس الشخص وانا
اعتقد قال ل تحتف لم هو سي سيد موفق مط
الشخص هذا الذي تقول بانه مقرب من حماس
اتينا بها اتينا بها من موقع الفيسبوك من
هو هذا الش من هذا هو الشخص تقول انه من
حماسس صفحه بهاء ياسين بهاء ياسين سيد
المشير مصري من هو بهاء ياسين هذا نعم نعم
من حماس وهذه
صورته وهذه صورته وهذه صورته ايضا مع
اسماعيل هنيه ومع قيادات من حماس هذا هو
هذا هو هذا هو الشخص الذي مفق يكمل س مفق
موافق مت من فضلك تفضل المشير
مصري اعتقد اخي الكريم يعني دون مقاطعه
حتى نضع نقوط نقاط على الحروف في هذه
المساله اعتقد ان المسؤوليه
الوطنيه التي ينبغي ان يتعامل بها الكل
الفلسطيني في هذه المرحله وفي المنعطفات
الحساسه لا ينبغي ان ت
من موقع على الفيسبوك او من شخص هنا وهناك
موقف حركه حماس واضح في هذه المساله هو
يتحدث عن شخص انا على صعيد الشخصي لا اعرف
هذا الشخص اصلا هل ينتمي لحركه حماس ام
لغيرها في هذا الجانب وليس هنا الموقف
الموقف ان حركه حماس كانت ستشارك في هذا
المهرجان ونتمنى ان يتم هذا المهرجان
واعتقد ان حركه حماس مسبقا وفي اطار حكمها
سمحت لحركه فتح بتنظيم مهرجان للراحل ياسر
عرفات منذ قبل وبعتقد ان الاهم في الذكرى
العاشره للراحل ياس عرفات الذي هو رمز
وطني وفلسطيني وهذا هو الموقف الذي تعبر
عنه حركه حماس بقيادتها وموقفها الرسمي
الاهم في الذكرى العاشره ان تكشف الجهه
التي تقف وراء اختيال الرائس الرئيس دكتور
احمد عزم دكتور احمد عزم الطرفان يتلقاني
هل هناك احتمال ان يكون هناك طرف ثالث
يريد ان يوقع بينهما ويخرب مسار
المصالحه يعني حتى لو حتى لو كان هناك طرف
ثالث يريد ان يوقع المصالحه المواطن
الفلسطيني بحاجه الى ان يعرف ما الذي حصل
فبالتالي هو يطلب من الاطراف المعنيه بان
توضح ما الذي حصل قبل ان يتم الحديث عن
طرف ثالث او الى غير ذلك المواطن
الفلسطيني يريد ان ايضا ان لا يتفاقم
الحدث الحالي المواطن الفلسطيني يريد عدم
استثمار ما يحدث حاليا من اعداء المصالحه
في الطرفين يريد ان ان ان لا يستثمر الحدث
بان تنجح مخططات من قام بالعمل المواطن
الفلسطيني يريد ان لا يستثمر الحدث بتبرير
المزيد من عمليات الاعتقال او التشدد و
وكبت الحريات وبالتالي المواطن الفلسطيني
قبل ان يتحدث عن طرف ثالث هو يتحدث عن
اصحاب المسؤوليه في الطرفين في كشف عن ما
حصل وفي وقف وعدم استمرار ما حدث بال
عندما تتحدث حركه حماس في واقع الامر عن
ضروره التحقيق وعن ضروره التحري وعن ضروره
تقديم مقترفي هذه الاعمال الى العداله
فالواقع ان هو طلب ال الى حد ما كمراقب
محايد غريب لان المتوقع هو ان تقوم حماس
بالتحقيق ان تقوم حماس بالتحري لان الامن
في قطاع غزه مازال مسؤوليه حركه حماس طيب
سنعود نواصل نقاشنا نناقش بعد الفاصل
مستقبل المصالحه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه على
ضوء الاثار التي تركتها تفجيرات القطاع
نرجو ان تبقوا معنا مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
الكرام اهلا بكم بكم من جديد في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش خلفيه تفجيرات غزه
وتاثيراتها المحتمله على مسار المصالحه
الفلسطينيه اهلا بضيوفنا الكرام مره اخرى
سيد موفق مطر هناك من نظر بعين الاستغراب
الى موقف السلطه الفلسطينيه وموقف حركه
فتح السريع رده الفعل السريعه التي رمت
بشكل مباشر الكره في ملعب حماس واتهمتها
بذلك وكان هناك موقف مستغرب ان يستنكف
وزير رئيس الحكومه السييد رامي الحمض الله
بتاجيل زيارته الى الى غزه بينما هو يشغل
منصب وزير الداخليه ايضا وبالتالي كان من
المطلوب ان يكون هو في مكان الحادث ويباشر
الاجراءات الامنيه والتحقيقات في عين
المكان بدل تاجيل زيارته لاجل غير
مسمى يا سيدي يا سيدي كلنا نعلم ان حماس
ما زالت مسيطره على بقوه السلاح منذ
الانقلاب منذ عام 2007 حتى هذه الساعه على
قطاع
غزه اليوم تحدث الاخ حسين الشيخ عضو
اللجنه المركزيه حول على الاقل حول موضوع
النقطه ا ا
لازالتها حتى لا تكون عائقا على الاقل
امام تنفيذ اليات اعاده
الاعمار كيف ممكن ان يذهب رئيس الحكومه
الى قطاع غزه قيمه 15 تفجيرا تنفذ في رئيس
الحكومه هذا اسمح لي رئيس الحكومه هذا
اتخذ موقفه وهذا باعتباره اسحي باعتباره
باعتبار انتمائه لحركه فتح وليس رئيس
حكومه لشعب باكمله يعني هذا موقف موقف
فصيل وليس موقف حكومه ما قام به رامي
الحمض لا لا لا لا هذا خطا هذا خطا ارجو
ارجو ارجو ان ارجو ان تسمح لي تفضل
الدكتور رامي الحمد الله هو رئيس حكومه
الوفاق الفلسطينيه التي لا يوجد بها ولا
حتى وزير ينتمي لفصيل فلسطين وهذا حسب
الاتفاق نرجوكم الا تكونوا الى جانب طرف
معين ه هو ليس رئيس حكومه فتح هو رئيس
حكومه الوفاق الفلسطينيه التي نالت
اعترافا عربيا ودوليا
وعالميا جهد جدييد من عمل القياده
السياسيه نرجو ان تكون الامور واضحه هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى نحن نحن لا الامر
لا يتعلق بزياره او تحقيق ما حدث يستهدف
الوعي الوطني يستهدف تمزيق النسيج الوطني
الفلسطيني يستهدف تحطيم ركائز الهويه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ما حدث خدمه مجانيه
لاسرائيل تشابه تماما عمليه خطف
المستوطنين الثلاثه التي اعترف بها صالح
العي وقدم خدمه مجانيه لاسرائيل
ا ي الفلسطيني ما يحدث اليوم هو عمليه
تغطيه وتعم
عن هذا ما يجب ان
يعلم الموضوع ليس موضوع تحقيقات عندما
عندما تترك حماس
الرسائل موجهه باسم الدوله الاسلاميه
بتاريخ هجري وثم تقول
ل المناضل اي انت فلان ايها صنديق الكافر
ممنوع ان تخرج من بيتك حتى 15/11 تستخدم
تاريخا ميلاديا هذا التزوير الواضح هذا
الغباء في التزوير واضح جيدا ودليل
علىه انا اسمح لنفسي ان اقول ال امامكم ان
هنالك مشكله داخل حماس وهذه
الع سؤالي اسالك وباختصار سي موفق متر
مصلحه حماس في القيام بهذه العمليه وهي
التي ت يعني كما تقول تحمل هم اعاده اعمار
غزه تحمل هم اعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها في
غزه وهي مقبله على فصل
الشتاء يعني انا اسسف صراحه لهذه اللغه في
التعامل في منعطف حساس تمر به القضيه
الفلسطينيه والملف الداخلي الفلسطيني وكان
الاولى ان ان ان يتم احترام العقل
الفلسطيني الذي يتابع هذه الاحداث
بكل بالتاكيد استغراب من الجهه التي تقف
المجرمه التي تقف وراء هذه الاحداث التي
لا مستفيد فلسطين المشير مصري سيد مشير
مصري انا كنت سالت وجهت هذا السؤال موفق
مطر ولكن بما انك انت اجبت اريد ان اسال
هنا عن افاق المصالحه لانه هناك اصوات من
داخل غزه منسوبه الى حماس في الفيسبوك
مثلا نشطاء على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اطلقوا على الفيسبوك حمله للاعتراض ومنا
اقامه مهرجان عرفات قبيل قبل اعتراف
الحكومه بالموظفين وتسليم العسكريين
رواتبهم يا اخي الكريم انا اعتقد انه في
المنعطفات الحساسه المواقف الوطنيه
الفصائل يجب ان تتحلى بالمسؤوليه الكبيره
في هذا الاطار بعيد عن التكهنات في في
الاتهام وبعيد عن الاستعجال في الاتهام
وبعيد عن اخذ مواقف من صفحه فيسبوك لشخص
هنا او لشخص هناك حركه حماس تعبر عن
موقفها عبر متحدثيها وبياناتها الرسميه
ولقاءاتها في هذا الاطار واعتقد ان موقف
الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي اجتمعت اليوم
اكدت على رفض الاتهامات السريعه التي لا
تستند الى حقائق والى دلائل في هذا ال
الجانب وكان الاولى بدل من الاستعجال في
هذه الاتهامات ان ان ان نتساءل هنا لماذا
لا تكون هناك اصابع خفيه تقف وراء هذه
التفجيرات
تسعى وخاصه اصابع صهيونيه تسعى لتعطيل
المصالحه الفلسطينيه التي ننشدها ونتطلع
اليها وسلمت في اطارها حركه حماس الحك هذا
ما اجاب عنه اجاب عنه دكتور احمد احمد عز
قال قبل قليل ا كانت الجهات هذه مسؤوليتكم
انتم لاظهار هذه الجهات التي تريد ان تخرب
المصالحه ومسار هنا اتوجه الى دكتور احمد
عزم مره اخرى اي افاق تبدو لهذه المصالحه
وهذا الغضب العارم في غزه مما يصفونه ببط
الرئيس الفلسطين محمود عباس في التعامل مع
مقتضيات تنفيذ اتفاق القاهره واطلاق مسار
المصالحه فعليا وتفعيل عمل الحكومه حكومه
التوافق
الوطني يعني ربما اتفق مع مشير المصري في
الحديث عن السرعه اذا لم اقل التسرع الذي
شاهدناه من حركه فتح في اتهام حركه حماس
قبل الحديث بالكثير من الادله ولكني اعتقد
انه بنفس المعيار هناك حديث عن بطء عند
حركه حماس في التصرف لكشف ما حصل عندما
نتحدث ويتحدث الاستاذ مشير المصري عن
اصابع اسرائيليه ربما تكون وراء الحدث
يعني لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن عمليه استمرت
لنحو ساعتين الى ساعتين ونص وفي 15 مكان
معنى ذلك ان القطاع غزه مخترق امنيا بشكل
هائل وهذا ما لم نراه في اثناء حرب غزه
الاخيره التي كان الصمود الامني وكان عدم
الخرق الاختراق الامني احد مظاهر الفخر
حتى لحركه حماس انا ذاك فبالتالي يعني
دعنا اقول انه هناك ادله ظرفيه كثيره هناك
الكثير من الاسئله حول ما الذي حدث في ح
في في غزه يعني كيف يمكن ان يحد تحدث
عمليه من هذا النوع اما بالنسبه للمصالحه
فالواقع المصالحه كما هو معروف فيها
الكثير من الالغام التي لم تحل يعني ربما
لم يكن يتوقع احد سيناريو مثل الذي حدث
اليوم ولكن هناك سيناريوهات كثيره تكتنف
طريق المصالحه من نوع مثلا لو كان الحرس
الرئاسي قد سيطر على المعابر من الذي
سيسيطر على الانفاق تحت الارض من الذي
سيسيطر على الحدود هناك الكثير من الامور
التي بحاجه الى حسم دون موقف واضح وجريء
من الفصائل ودون مواق موقف ودون حسم نهائي
لجميع وقائع المصالحه لا يمكن ان نصل الى
مصالحه يعني عدم زياره رامي الحمد الله
الى قطاع غزه نعم قد تثير من ناحيه نظريه
استغراب لان المسؤول عندما يقع اي حدث في
في بلده هو يسارع الى الزياره حتى لو لم
يكن مقررا مثل هذه الزياره حتى لو لم يكن
رامي الحمد الله مقررا ان يزور قطاع غزه
غدا ربما نتوقع ان يزورها بعد هذا الحادث
ولكن في نفس الوقت دعنا نقول هل لد رامي
الحمد الله صلاحيات كامله لان ياتي بالف
الفريق الامني الذي يريده للتحقيق هل
بامكانه ان يقود تحقيق حقيقي في قطاع غزه
كلها اسئله يجب ان يجاب عليها من جميع
الاطراف بشفافيه لا يمكن ان تستمر عمليه
القاء اللوم من هنا الى هناك هناك قواعد
يعرفها اي شخص محايد مراقب اي خبير امني
يمكن ان يقول ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث لكي
يحدث امن في قطاع غزه لا يمكن ان تستمر
ازدواجيه الامن الحاليه ولا يمكن ان تستمر
عمليه كل طرف يريد ان يسجل نقاط في عند
الطرف الاخر ط طيب موفق موفق مطر كان هناك
ايضا من بين الفرضيات التي طرحت حول
المدبرين لهذه العمليه ان هي ان هذه
العمليه جاءت كتجي لصراع فتحاوي داخلي
هناك من توجه باصابع الاتهام
لانصار دحلان في صراعهم الرئيس محمود عباس
بدليل ان يعني اراك تبتسم ولكن هذا موجود
في الصحف في الاعلام الفلسطيني بان هناك
شجار وقع ساعات قبل شجار عنيف وقع بين
انصار عباس ودحلان في جامعه الازهر في غزه
خلال تكريم عائلات الشهداء ساعات قبل وقوع
ما حدث وبان اغلب البيوت التي استهدفت ل
الفتحاويين هم الفتحاويين من انصار الرئيس
عباس
وا
وايضا هنالك من فجرت منازلهم ايضا ممن
يممكن القول ان انهم محسوبون على دحلا هذا
لا ليس كلام منطقيا انا استغرب كيف يقول
للاخ مشير المصري ان ان ان التي خرجت
منتصره من الحرب وانها تستطيع تحديد متى
يعود المستوطنين الى
مستوطناتهم ثم لا تستطيع ان تحدد من قام ب
15 تفجير متزامن هذا امر حقيقه عمليه
استخفاف الوعي الانسان والمواطن الفلسطيني
يا سيدي لننتبه هنا لننتبه هنا الى امر
مهم جدا على حماس ان تبحث عن من قام في
هذا العمل من داخل حماس هنالك بحماس من من
تتعارض مصالحه الشخصيه والذاتيه والفيه
وايضا المرتبطه حتى حت حتى العظم مع جماعه
الاخوان الم هذا تسا مطروح للمشير المصري
قبل ان ينتهي وقت البرنامج مشير المصري رد
هذا الكلام لان هناك دقيقه فق البنام
اتف انهم جوا يا اخ موفق بس اصبر شويه
موفق اصبر شويه انا بعتقد للاسف لغه سياسه
سياسه خلط الاوراق لا تجوز هنا وهناك
حكومه وفاق وطني يجب ان تتحمل مسؤولياتها
بدل من ان تلغي زياراتها ليتفضل السيد
الحمد الله بصفته رئيس وزراء ووزير
الداخليه ويتفضل سيد محمود عباس ليتحملوا
مسؤولياتهم في الاشراف على التحقيقات التي
جرت اذا كان لحركه فتح اذا كان لحركه فتح
اذا كان لحركه فتح اذا كان لحركه فتح اي
اسماء واي معلومات عليها ان تسلم ذلك الى
لجان التحقيق بدل من الاتهامات الجاهزه
التي كانت بعد تقاء دقائق من القيام بهذه
التفجيرات هذه الاحداث تحدث في كل دول
العالم التحقيقات تجري واعتقد ان الاجزه
الامنيه قادره ان تصل الى الجناه لكن يبقى
السؤال ربما ان تكون هناك ايدي خفيه
صهيونيه ربما ان تكون امتداد لخلافات
داخليه في حركه فتح والتي كان اخرها
بالامس في جامعه الازهر وقبل ذلك شكرا
مصري
شراير المصير شكرا المشير المصري القيا في
حركه
حماس شكرا لكشري شكرا لك موفق مطر عضو
المجلس الثوري لحركه فتح من رام الله
ونشكر ايضا الدكتور احمد عزم استاذ
الدراسات الدوليه في جامعه بزيت بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ا